So we're can talk about domes and we're gonna talk about one of the largest and
possibly one of the most famous in the world here in the UK. So in London, St.
Paul's cathedral,
it's a very large theater and there's right in the center of London and has this
really imposing dome. One of the biggest in the world,
they amateur is 34 meters. The question becomes,
how do you build the correct shape of dome so that it
will sit under its own weight without supports without mass?
How do you actually create that? And that's a math problem.
So that's what we're going to figure out. Okay, great. Fire of London,
1666 had just happened and suppose was really badly damaged and they wanted to
rebuild this grand cathedral, Christopher Brown,
very famous architect of the time he was given the task of rebuilding this
cathedral.
And he wanted this big dome to kind of be the centerpiece of the cathedral.
And at the time he was really good friends with a famous physicist Robert hook,
and they kind of worked together to try and think about how can we have the
largest dome possible that doesn't need any support.
And because Robert hook was a physicist and a mathematician,
he thought about this mathematically and his amazing insight
was to actually use, basically use nature to help us figure this out.
So what he did was I think he used a chain,
but it's the same with a piece of string and you just hold your two ends.
Like so, so their level, so my hands were about level,
and then you just let it form its shape.
So this forms a sort of U shape kind of looks like a parabola or an X squared
graph, perhaps. And this is actually sort of, well,
it's nature being lazy,
easiest way to describe it because what's happening here is it's forming the
sheep. That minimize is the energy of the, of the string.
So the potential energy from gravity,
pulling it down is minimized in this shape. So, and if I move my hands,
it will obviously adjust its shape,
still forming this kind of U shape and re Hawk's idea was to say,
well, this is forming to minimize the energy.
So if we flip it up, because when it was hanging,
it was minimizing its energy.
And the way it was doing that is by spreading out the weight as much as
possible. So suddenly when you flip it upside down,
you've got your dome where your weight is spread out as much as possible.
And so that is going to help you to build the biggest possible dome.
You can basically using nature as like a guide or a blueprint of how to do this.
And this is basically, this is what they did. So,
so if you actually look at the original plans for St Paul's or even the drawings
of the, of the building itself, it actually uses this idea and the shape.
So the outer dome, it was a very big hemisphere. This is 34 meters in diameter,
right across the bottom here.
And then this kind of then comes down a bit down here is the inner dome,
which is also a Hemisfair like this,
and this one's a little bit smaller that doesn't quite go to the edge.
The inside one is 30 meters. So when you're inside some Pauls,
you can look up and you can see all the beautiful artwork on the ceiling.
That's the inner dome, not the outer one that you can see from outside.
They're two separate domes. And the inner one is a little bit smaller,
three meters, less across the sphere and sort of the perfection of it.
And the cemetery has symbolic meaning.
So that was why these had to be spherical. This is kind of what Ren was told,
but of course he wanted to, to make it strong, make it, uh, you know,
use maths to help us build this thing.
So what they did was on the inside bit in here
was actually create a third dome.
And this is the shape of the hanging chain or the shape of my piece of string.
So this thing in here is actually what's bearing all of the load.
So you have these kinds of spiritual shells on the outside,
and all of the weight is actually supported by the hanging string or the hanging
chain sheet in the middle. That's doing the business. Yeah.
That's the one that's actually supporting.
The dome. So the staff at and all that.
Yeah. I'm not sure he's quite this pointy, but it's definitely not.
It's definitely not a hemisphere. As we saw when I was hanging it,
it wasn't a sphere. It was very much more like a U shape.
So this is supporting all of the weight. Now they figured this out.
So this was the idea like literally hooked to these experiments was like,
this is the shape we need to build. Now, the only problem they had was this,
this was the 60, 60 or 60 seventies.
And to actually know the shape, this hanging chain shape,
you need a, an area of math school, calculus variations,
and that was not discovered or invented until the 1750s,
a hundred years later with these new techniques,
this calculus of variations as it was called,
which has actually worked on mainly by oil and the grunge.
So two very big name of petitions of 17 hundreds.
So with calculus of variations,
you can show the exact shape that this needs to be.
And it's something called a [inaudible]
. This is the exact shape of our hanging string. But the dome itself in St
Paul's is like a very good approximation of bit
, but that's nothing against hook and ran. They
just didn't yet have the mathematical tools. They needed to get the exact shape. So they were basing it almost on like an approximation and experiment.
So they literally kind of like traced.
More or less. Yeah. And it's really interesting.
You can actually look at the original drawings and you can see that they are
literally just like kind of sketching what the shapes should be based on the
shape of a huggy.
J so even though they didn't have the right mathematical tools,
they had the insight to actually put them to work. And it obviously works.
The dome is still there today. So now that we do have the tools,
the shape itself is something called a CAUTI curve or a hyperbolic
co-sign. So with the full tools of carcass, the variations you can show,
you can set this problem up hanging chain. I want to minimize energy.
And your answer is this cost curve. So then what we want to know is, well,
what on earth is a cost curve? And that's what I'm gonna need. More paper.
Costs.
Of X. So this is the actual shape we want for the,
for the [inaudible] for the perfect dome shape.
The cash function is an exponential function.
So the starting point actually here to figure out what's going on with cosh is
to consider the function E to the ax.
So ear to the X is a function which has an expansion,
which is one plus X plus X squared divided by two
factorial, plus X cubed, over three factorial plus.dot dot.
And the graph of this function goes through one like, so that's zero.
And then it decreases never quite gets to zero. And then this bit increases.
So this would be Y equals each of the X. So as you can see, as X gets bigger,
you're just adding together lots and lots of powers of X.
So the thing's going to grow really quickly. This is exponential growth.
Now the cost term is very similar to the exponential,
but what you say is I just want the even terms
in this song. So I want X to the zero, which is one.
I want X squared. I want X to the four. I want X to the sex.
I'm just going to take me even powers of X and let's see what happens.
And that's basically how you define cosh.
It's the even terms of your exponential.
So you would write then cosh of X is
one plus X squared,
because of course two is even plus X to the four, because four is even,
and we carry on in that way. You can also think about reflecting its graph.
So when you have an even function, well, that means there's,
it's the same either side of the y-axis.
So if we kind of take this bit of the graph, reflect it,
this is basically the Costco,
which is the nice dome shape and the nice hanging string sheet that we had.
It would be Y equals cost of X. Now cosh comes from the even terms,
maybe you're thinking, well, what about the odd terms?
And obviously we have a function for that. Uh,
so if we do the odd terms and that is going to be showing of X,
just like this is hyperbolic cause hyperbolic sign,
and this one is going to then be X cause that's,
what's the power one X cubed plus X to the five.
So it's just all your odd powers and shine of X. It's the same up here.
This one goes through zero. So it's a bit more like an X cubed graph.
It's got that kind of kink, almost like Ash shape to it.
And this one can be negative because you've got,
if you still be negative values of X,
you're gonna get minuses from the old powers.
Whereas negative IDs of X appear give you positives. So Kosh stays positive,
but shine can go negative. So we have these two functions, uh,
and then there's actually a shorthand way that you can write a CAUTI as well,
using the exponential formula as you consider ear to the minus X.
So you just take your ear to the X formula,
but wherever there's an ax you plug into minus X. So plus ax,
that becomes a minus X squared. So minus one squared is just one.
So I still get plus X squared over two,
then I'll get minus execute over three factorial or carry on.
So the terms, the sign alternates, when you plug in minus X.
So now if you take each to the minus X and each of the X,
if we add them together, so we do eat to the X plus E to the minus X,
you can add them together and I'm going to divide by two because I'm going to
get one plus one. Then when I divide by two, this moving one,
I've got plus X and minus X, they disappear. I then got two,
lots of the X squared term, five divided by two.
So I just get plus X squared to material.
The cubic one has gotten negative here. It's got a positive, they disappear.
So there'll be no cubic term X to the fourth. And then we carry on.
And of course this is quarterbacks.
Even the even terms exactly as we defined it here, but now you can rate it.
And it's really nice shorthand formula.
It's just easily expertly to the minus X divided by two.
What's the variable here. If I want to go home and build a dome on my house,
what's the, you know, which is not as wide as St. Paul's cathedral.
What's the thing I need to change, like to get my graph. So.
If you are to draw the graph of costs,
so depending on how wide you want your dome,
this is going to tell you that the shape. So if your Dome's really narrow,
let's call it five meters.
Then you would go up here and you're going to get a very kind of wide flat dome
in that instance. Whereas if you're going to like some poles, which let's say,
maybe that's all the way out to here, that distance is your 34 meters,
then you're getting this kind of bigger shape.
So all of them follow the same graph.
So the other thing that will change is the length of the string.
And this is actually,
this comes up in the full calculus of variations way of solving
the problem you do have to input my string is of this fixed length.
So, so the solution does depend on the length of your string.
So if I have my fixed length of string here, then I form this particular shape.
But then if I say, right, well, I'm only going to have this bit of string,
and there's still that far apart. I've got, I'm a shallower dome now,
but no matter what length of string you have and how far apart my hands are,
all of these shapes that are being formed are Kosh curbs.
They are all hyperbolic co-sign curbs. You've just got a variable in that,
which is representing the fact that the length or the distance is changing.
So no matter what droop I'm seeing there in the string. Yeah, it is,
it is some variation of that same curve on scene.
Well, a hyperbolic cost code. Yes. In all of these situations,
the answer is yes.
The Costco. I'm just sort of seeing it at different zooms.
Yeah. Yeah.
So either at different zooms or you can cause if I put them really close
together, now it's a very different shape, but that is still a cost curve.
You could still write down the actual formula. So, so the,
the F the full formula will be cautious of
something where that something depends on the length of your string.
Depends on how far apart you are.
So there are variables that you have to input to get the exact answer,
but everything that comes out is this hyperbolic coastline function ran and
hook. Didn't like Kosh didn't exist until the 1760s.
So it wasn't even a function.
So they literally had no chance of knowing that this was the shape they needed
to build this dope. So they just had to take like best guesses.
And they kind of did this through almost knowing what it wasn't.
So do their experiments with the hanging chains and the string.
They knew it wasn't an X squared.
So they were definitely sure it wasn't the parabola. So then they kind of tried,
well, what's the next simplest thing I could have. Maybe it's a cubic.
Maybe it's a Y equals X cubed. So if we were to plot Y equals X cubed,
and we're just going to add one to it,
so that it goes through one instead of zero,
just because cosh also goes through one, if we were to draw away cause X cubed,
plus one, it would look like that hair.
And then it would kind of go down like this,
what ran and hooked did was they reflected it.
So then we kind of extend it this way.
So it is believed that the actual shape of this inner
dome at St Paul's is an X cubed curve.
That is what we, what we believe at the moment. They actually based this on.
And it's a really good approximation to the Costco cash curve.
On top of this, it basically looks kind of the same,
very similar at the start it does eventually come through.
And then what happens at really large values of X is because the cash is an
exponential function. Exponential functions will always beat to polynomials.
This is why exponential growth is such an issue in such a thing,
because exponential is, will eventually grow faster than a polynomial.
So it will eventually beat the execute.
So even though it sort of starts inside and then comes outside,
eventually it comes back up,
up here and becomes narrower because it grows faster. So the, the idea,
the thing that clearly, um, ran and hook spotted was that,
you know,
they're drawing the red curve is based on their experiments with the string and
the hanging chains.
And they clearly spotted that the ax cube does a really good job of capturing
that.
And so we believe that that is actually what they used to build that in a dome
at St. Paul's that's taking all of the weight,
allowing such a big dome to do actually exist.
[Inaudible].
This episode has been supported by Kiwi co and today I'm making an
infinity mirror from their tinker crate,
keep co delivers all sorts of crates with different themes,
different target ages,
just take a pick from their website and find one on your doorstep. Every month.
It's like Christmas, all year round.
Everything you're gonna need is already in the box.
Even the batteries are included when necessary. These are great for kids,
including slightly bigger and older kids like me.
It's a real learning experience.
Sometimes I didn't even realize how clever this was until after I'd made.
The thing gave me a bit of an insight into how things get made. Actually,
the address is there on the screen, Kiwi code.com/number file.
That's going to get you 50% of your first month on any crepe,
Kiwi code.com with that slash number far,
and take a look at that. Lover, a Kiwi code subscription,
make a great Christmas or birthday present.